by the power of castle hate skull i am
hella mark harley and you are someone
who i love if you are watching the show
if you're tuning in again from last week
after seeing me for the first time i
appreciate that i appreciate the
turnover your willingness to not just
give me a chance but give me a second
chance all right so thank you if you're
viewing and if you're a longtime viewer
and listener thank you as well too i
appreciate you just the same okay so
oh boy it's so good to be on this
channel on the fake boy channel because
more people get to see this show right
we had some pretty good views this last
week and i just want to say i don't care
about the views per se in the sense that
is it just about getting more views of
course i'd like to get more views but if
i'm putting out like garbage prank
content you know and harassing elderly
people on the street to get views
that is not meaningful to me if i can
put out a good show and continue to grow
my viewership by putting out quality
content and growing via the word of
mouth and you telling your friends that
this is something you might want to tune
into that's what i will be proud of so
hopefully you got something out of the
last episode if you watched um
hopefully you feel free to comment and
say oh i like this part i didn't like
that part do more of this and less of
that i'm trying to make the show run
more efficiently so i don't want to
ramble on and you know fill it up with
stuff that people don't want to hear
about but that's going to be a process
that i have to figure out with you guys
you can tell me what do you like what do
you not like so
good god so much to talk about
first off
went to a comedy show last night
shop and friends at the improv
fantastic show goddamn
normal lineup with justin elliott david
lucas chappelle lacey brendan shop and
chris dalia and [ __ ] man it was just
an amazing audience everybody killed it
like i just you know having seen
justin david brendan and chappelle
perform many times before i felt like
everybody's set had a little something
extra in it you know a little you know
as you see comedians make little tweaks
and
you know add act outs or just you know
find certain moments that's really cool
i'd never seen chris delia perform matin
his specials
but i'd never actually seen him perform
live and
seeing him live in addition to the fact
that he's doing a lot of new material
based on his evolution as a human
um was really cool because he's somebody
with a tremendous comedic skill set who
can make so many people laugh just
based on like voices and goofiness and
silliness and act outs like he has this
this tool set that you know he can he
can make you laugh a lot of different
ways
what he's added
seemingly uh in the past couple years is
a layer of depth
and vulnerability that i think really
works so if you have a chance to see him
live it's a really
incredible set i'll try to leave it at
that not you know go into anything too
specific but i'm just going to say that
when people add these elements of
storytelling and kind of you know uh
bringing vulnerability to talk about
themselves in ways they haven't before
or you know talk about their family and
things that you know as a guy or
especially as a comedian a lot of people
develop a sense of humor to keep people
at arm's length and that's something he
talks about in his set
that uh you know
via therapy and just working on his self
was able to break that down and i just
think it makes for incredible
entertainment when you can combine that
with the laughs that you you know would
have gotten anyway i'm not saying you
you know give up give up the jokes to
just go you know have a ted talk
about your emotions but
if you can synthesize those two special
things will come so amazing show glad i
saw it
um went with little brows
and uh after the show little brows was
talking to crystallia and i ran up to
him like uh hey brows did you get the
feature of the the eminem feature from
crystalia did you ask him about that
like asking you know as as if i talked
about in the car with him like
okay remember when we talked to did you
ask him yet come on dude
don't puss out just ask him like he
knows eminem you can get the feature
think boy come on dude
super awkward but that's what i live for
okay
christian what'd you think of the show
last night
i thought it was amazing yeah what'd
your mom think my mom uh it was great
she it was the first time i think she
saw uh brian so she was excited to see
that she started oh yeah sorry i
forgot to mention brian that was also my
first time seeing brian which was also
really really cool yeah
first time seeing brian first time
seeing david she like had a blast she
loved it yeah yeah it was a lot of fun i
thought everyone crushed it last night
casey how was it not seeing that show
last night
it was chill i went to bed at nine
all right so uh another thing that i
want to talk about because i talked
about my auditions last week and like
what i expected happened and basically
the exact thing that i that happened did
that horror movie didn't hear anything
back but the one
uh that i was more excited about and
talking with the director what really as
well as it could have gone and that
ended itself as a validating moment
because you're like damn i thought it
would go like this it did go like that
can't say anything more but you know
you'll be
the moment i can talk about it you'll be
the first to hear about it um
but just a validating moment as far as
like yeah i thought i was right for this
and it
got to talk with the director whose work
i really admire
somebody who's like oh yeah you're
talking about wanting me and your
project and i i love your movies i think
they're absolutely brilliant
that's cool and just to relate to him on
a personal level tool he's a cool guy
and it's always cool seeing people who
are like oh you're like famous
successful you do amazing artwork and
you just seem like a really down to
earth person as well that's always very
cool to experience man oh man my little
brother andy
is getting back into working out i've
talked about him before his struggles
with
weight uh
you know
various injuries just life happening to
you
um
he hit me up the other day he was like
i'm ready to do it ready to get back
into it ready to diet ready to start
working out
ready to start you know doing cardio and
just losing this weight um
i said why don't we get you back in the
gym too because he didn't belong to a
gym so we signed him up for a gym
membership uh because i think that's a
big part of it when you used to lift
when you're an athlete
you can lose weight without lifting but
i just think it's a fun thing to do as
you build muscle you know
you're going to look better when you
lose that fat right instead of going to
that the other side of the spectrum
people do this crazy amount of cardio
eventually your metabolism is going to
really slow down as you lose muscle in
addition to the fat when you're not
lifting weights or not eating a high
protein diet so
you're just more likely to end up with
saggy skin
not looking your best looking sort of
frail or skinny fat after losing a bunch
of fat uh rather than you know
full
filling out that loose skin with your
muscles
so what i did was i know i've talked
about dc training a number of times here
and i'll usually send people links or
articles and say hey here's what dc
training is and um but
because when you go to an article online
usually like it's full of ads and it's
like they want you to get to the next
paragraph keep scrolling so it's always
like non-succinct so i sat down and
wrote out
an entire intro to dc training for him
explaining just the basics and giving
him
six example workouts because that's what
at any given time you only really be
doing six different variations
of the workout because it's an upper and
lower day as a beginner
you add another a day in there i believe
it's as an advanced dc trainer but
if you
do upper lower and you have three
different options for each movement
that you do in those days you have three
different workouts for your upper body
and lower body so i wrote all those out
and gave him specific examples
and sent it off and he really liked it
because i think for people who aren't
inherently interested in lifting like i
take for granted i could be in the gym i
don't mind i don't mind training for two
hours i don't think it's the smartest
thing but like i enjoy weightlifting
inherently more i enjoy being in the gym
andy's not necessarily like that he
works really hard in the gym
but is he gonna be psyched to be there
for as long as he can though he wants to
get in and get out as most people do
dc training is cool because it's like
it's it strips all the bs out and you're
just trying to beat yourself on these
core lifts every week so i say all that
to say to you
and i don't even know if i can think is
this the best way to solicit your
contact information
drop your email and i will afford you
the email i sent him that breaks down dc
training with the
actual workouts in it or if you hit me
up on ig i will send you
the document just throwing it out there
if you want to see my little take on dc
training you can do that oh goodness
gracious
we have some mark harley memes of the
week and again i'm st i'm gonna start
incorporating other memes too but these
are just ones that people have made of
me um i don't know who this guy is in
the arts we see me and uh you know an
accurate but unflattering
visual comparison to another guy i guess
he's super big in england like when i
posted this initially from uh sebastian
maddox made it
everybody's like oh my god he's a legend
in you know england or whatever or no
russia that's what it is he's a legend
way off mark do some basic research into
who
you're going to be talking about on the
podcast
doesn't matter i just think you get it
doesn't matter where he's from
it's hilarious either way with the gray
and purple and the mustache i just you
know it's accurate but hurtful the
second one is
dude's name mark on the left with a k
dude's name mark on the right also
accurate not hurtful to me because i
gotta k in my name um seriously who
spells their name with a c these days
good god grow up
finally
you know i'm not in the business of
making memes but
i am somebody who has made a meme before
and that's right there you're looking at
it
classic
guy in the corner of the party set up
right like we've seen so many times
before and i think some really funny
memes have come from such a simple
format
and it just says
they don't know i'm the buffest person
on instagram because they probably don't
because they're ignorant and stupid and
i don't like you
and finally
this guy daniel rabone he's a the most
prolific mark harley meme creator
to ever exist
he constantly sends me these funny
photoshops i actually try to put them
all on my uh save stories or the story
highlights whatever those are called uh
this one's the 40 year old hater with my
face photoshopped onto steve carl's body
on the poster of the 40 year old version
not 40 yet guys
everybody that's that's one of my haters
favorite thing to say you're 40.
um 38.
and of course got another liver king
meme of the week
every we're gonna be trying to do liver
king stuff every week because he's my
favorite fitness influencer of all time
at this point
little kid looking up
dad can we get a happy meal
liver king looks down no son we're
having cow balls and liver again
and i mean again it's accurate
i'm sure he's feeding his k his kid bold
testicles all right i want to do real
quick cool [ __ ] i saw on the internet
this week right that's a new segment
just because you know i see a lot like
it's not just fitness [ __ ] that i see
that i think is cool here we have
a guy must be in russia right where else
would it be arm wrestling a bear and the
bear is surprisingly compliant in this
endeavor it's always shocking it's like
the bear knows what's up bears are smart
bears know when habib and magameto is
trying to wrestle
they know when this guy is trying to arm
wrestle and puts up some resistance and
kind of just generally he's playing by
the rules you know he's leaning over and
he's gripping with one hand and he's not
biting or cheating or anything
it's uh it's a pretty amazing little
thing that they just got the bear to be
able to do this
he seems like a pretty cool bear not
gonna lie
okay
next one we have
we'll get some volume on that listen to
these guys tapping away
[Music]
two redheaded twins perhaps doing uh
irish step dancing now true irish step
dancing involves keeping your arms
totally still at your side so they are
breaking the rules here but i think the
outcome is tremendously cool i mean look
at these guys they're just completely in
sync
the little
little things on their feet that make it
you know is that tap dancing i don't
know but i think it's irish step dancing
like
uh
tap dancing is a close relative of that
but to me this is cool and i've just
always been obsessed with irish step
dancing
i don't know why you know it just looks
cool to me and it looks impressive um
and uh you know i'm thinking about
signing up for classes to be in like a
class with little kids learning irish
stuff dancing that'd be fun huh we could
document it all for the youtube page
all right
so i wanted to do a saucy or not on
bruce wayne not bruce wayne as played by
christian bale or any other actor who
has played them but i had this idea of
like you know because i just
doing the normal natty or not for people
by the time that they get around to me
gregory said or more plates more dates
or all these people are gonna already
have done them and frankly it's not as
interesting of a discussion to me to
just look at people unless they're so
big and so obvious and um they're so
fraudulent and claiming that they're
natural and they're actually not um but
usually by that point people have
already given them attention for that
um and done a number of nation or knots
and it's almost like not kicking
somebody when it's down but it just
becomes redundant it's like yeah
you know when the fitness industry stops
incentivizing people to be fake 90s i
think that might become a more
interesting conversation but for now
i just thought i'd take a little more
abstract and go in the world of batman
and the dc universe is bruce wayne
natural or is he not right so on the
side of him being uh natural
uh you'd have the evidence that he never
talks about steroids at all unless i'm
mistaking does he ever talk about
steroids
not once not once okay yeah cause like
i'm you know i'm somewhat
knowledgeable i like i used to like read
and and
uh watch the uh read batman comics and
watch the cartoon as a kid and you know
i have enough awareness to know i don't
think i ever saw him do that but um
so we have to assume they're trying to
project an image at least or that he's
trying to project and he's not telling
all the criminals like i'm on dianabol
right now
you don't want to mess with me
what's the difference between a guy like
me and a guy like you
i'm on tren
um so
the idea is in that world he's being
proposed to be a natural
bodybuilder i mean what could you we'd
never see him lift weights either that's
uh he's like what's batman's training
routine right obviously he's in
tremendous shape and can do all these
physical themes uh
we're i'm not really sure how old he's
supposed to be or whatever but let's
just look at these images here right so
on the side of he's natural he never
talks about it he has access to all the
things that you would need to maximize
your own natural gains he can eat
whatever he wants private chef he can
sleep all freaking day he has all the
time in the world to lift he has vast
resources um
to help him train and recover
naturally
right so you could make the argument
that well whatever he's just like peak
natty lifter status but then you look at
pictures like this of how they render
him and because he's a a superhero but
he doesn't have super powers like he can
sort of buy the idea that like oh yeah
superman's super strong and he can
you know lift trains up and [ __ ] like
that it's like yeah we'd expect him to
be buff he's also from another planet so
he's not bound by the laws of you know
human anatomy in the same exact way
right
but when batman is a comparable physique
i mean
look at those shoulders look at those
traps
talk about androgen receptors filling up
capped ass delts he's at least nine
percent body fat perhaps less gigantic
biceps now it does look like he's
skipping leg day a little bit i'll be
honest right sort of disproportionate
with that hulking upper body and minimal
quad development but i'll give him a
pass you know we're trying to make
something look exaggerated
and uh
i think maybe his logic is like oh i'm
more agile when my legs aren't so big
you know but let's be real you're
skipping leg day bro it's okay
let's scroll down to that next pick
which is a slightly more realistic
rendering if you saw a
picture of a guy that looked like this
and this is you know more photorealistic
with
the veins the striations it's
anatomically more accurate
um
gigantic arms gigantic forearms
uh
full six-pack ripped obliques rip
serratus so here he looks like he could
be you know six percent body fat
if he's six feet tall it looks like he's
about 240 pounds right
i'm gonna have to say bruce wayne in the
world of the dc universe is not natural
and he's lying to everybody batman is a
fraud
and i get it you came up
in a time when it wasn't uh okay to talk
about that sort of thing
in the world of comics but i just hope
that he takes a cue from some of these
other fitness influencers and comes out
and comes clean and tells the people who
follow him so closely my physique isn't
attainable naturally okay
i think the fans would respect it i
think the villains would respect it too
it's like you know
maybe that's all they wanted the whole
time is like they're angry about bruce
wayne lying about his natty status and
that's why they're causing all this
trouble in the city
who knows but
bruce wayne
it's okay dude
everybody's on steroids that's the great
nate diaz once said
okay
i wanted to do a quick hella sick
fitness page
this is one of those pages his name is
alec on kiri on curie elite fitness as
the youtube page you spell it
e-n-k-i-r-i
so this is a guy he's only like 30 000
youtube uh subscribers and i only point
that out to say
like you're
this guy is sort of undiscovered i think
he's growing at a good pace but like he
has
top-tier information it's just that he's
not one of these guys that's putting a
lot of flash and panash into everything
and this is killing your gains and
that's killing your gains but as far as
giving practical advice for especially
explosive movements because this guy's
really good at uh
like for how big he is he's tremendously
strong and i think you always have to
look for that kind of stuff when you're
looking at somebody like does can he
deliver that for himself you know he's
i think he's like around 160 or
something
and i've seen him do like zombie squats
what's like a front squat with your arms
up like that with 405 for reps um
he
you know can hang clean like 250 plus a
lot of really impressive lips just given
his size and the fact that he's natty
claims to be naughty and i totally
believe him there's no indication that
he's on steroids but
he uh also
i don't know what his exact 40 time is
but i've seen him do some sprints and
other like explosive [ __ ] where he has
impressive numbers as far as vertical
jump sprint agility drills like if i was
a football player if i was if you're in
high school or something like that
looking for a program to improve your
athleticism go to this guy because he
knows what he's talking about does all
the experimentation on itself there's no
gimmicks
there's no um
bs i just think he's he's all about like
what works
uh and he's super i love how he writes
out his videos super articulate super in
depth and uh you're you're
going to learn something from going to
his page if you're into lifting weights
to improve your athletic performance
the final thing i'll say about him which
goes into
um
you know the next uh
segment here is that he did he did a
video on
uh athlean x
that
rocked the internet he called athlete x
out
for essentially being
uh a bser right a fraud and i'm going to
transition that into the fitness fraud
of the week being athlete x
but first i'll just say
he made this video and came out and the
main points are jeff cavaliere right
who's one of the biggest fitness
influencers on youtube 12 million
subscribers and he's like a physical
therapist but kind of
you know putting the science back in
strength he's not a strength coach okay
he has a certified strength and
conditioning specialist certificate
which i also had at the age of 23. this
does not make you an expert in strength
programming by any means and most of
what i've learned in the industry has
come after that as far as you know
actual uh
real world applicability to programming
you know or even learning how to do some
of the basic lifts the main points of
alex critique of athlete x
that i agree with
he doesn't know how to perform a squat
properly he does a demonstration where
he has the
the lifter breathe out
expel all his air with the bar on his
back before doing the rep that's the
opposite of what you should do right so
if you're a strength coach you should
know those basics
and you shouldn't be putting out any
videos
saying you know misinformation like that
and if you do you should switch it up
you should put out an apology video
secondly got caught using fake weights
he did a 500 pound deadlift looked off
did some research into it
he cannot deadlift that much and he
tried to make up for it but being like
oh here's a real deadlift with 420 or
something like that like but he did it
in a passive aggressive way where
um like he didn't say oh you know this
is me
making up for the fact that i did a fake
lift before he just sort of like did it
but it looked totally different it's
like if you're cat-backing with 425 you
can't deadlift 500 pounds sorry
i also got caught with fake weights
using like 315 for close grip bench
press and again caught i mean like you
can just tell by the way somebody lifts
and how big they are he's potentially on
hrt and lies about it
and uh his programming is utter [ __ ]
the programs that he sells they're not
good he also messes up things like
german volume training or like there was
he had some recommendation of like a 10
rep a 10 set
squat workout
where the percentage of your max that he
recommended and the time
that uh he was advocating you rest made
the whole thing impossible and multiple
fitness influencers like tried to do it
and showed how you can only maybe make
it to set three halfway through with
this percentage of your max and this
rest time showing that this guy doesn't
know what the [ __ ] he's talking about
and he's making money off you like all
fitness frauds this guy
does know something but he's
exaggerating that expertise
and positioning him as himself as an
expert in the field of strength and
conditioning and strength programming
when in fact he is not alec on kiri
received a ton of backlash for that but
held his ground i mean every major like
fitness
page was like
defending athlean x and simping for him
but at the end of the day alec makes the
best points
cool dude
what should i freaking okay so one thing
that i wanted to do this week
is
a help
ah i'm on steroids for myself can you
believe it
i don't know what the what the
temperature in the room is well it's
nice and cool it's 72 in here but as far
as what you guys want to know from me
about my own steroid use i'm going to be
totally open about it if you want to
hear about it i'm not going to waste an
hour talking about something that nobody
gives a thing about
but
if you want to know i'll tell you and
i'll start off by just saying this
uh currently i'm in week three of taking
a hundred milligrams of nandrolone
phenoproprionate a day and that's it uh
now
i have not done nandralone
since i was in college that was part of
the first cycle that i ever took which i
can get into what i've taken before and
the periods where i was natural
if you're interested comment below you
know if you're interested in hearing
more about that and i can make that a
weekly segment because again there's so
much information out there but i try to
always pair it with what my experience
is and if i haven't directly experienced
something i'm not going to talk about it
as if i had um but nandrillon is
something after i first took it i
thought i'd never take it again because
i had side effects from it that i wanted
to avoid but turns out as i look more
interesting oh that's probably side
effects like prolactin increasing when
you combine it with testosterone um
getting acne probably not you know
attributable to nandrolone in the stack
i was taking initially so my experience
so far on android alone 700 milligrams a
week has been nothing
but positive um it's
a milder androgen than testosterone it's
more hair safe than testosterone
and you know so far i've been
experiencing
no side effects in general and i can go
more into
why i chose to do that probably next
week
and it's all because of a guy named tyan
clark
he i never would have been open to a an
angelo only cycle but i went to his page
and we're going to do a
segment on this guy next week but he's
blown my mind in the past few weeks with
just i love people who take conventional
wisdom
and turn it on its head right so he has
a lot of stuff like this like doing oral
only cycles um you know he has articles
on here long versus short cycle so he's
i'm gonna do seven weeks of the npp then
angelo um
because
he wrote an article about how 90 of your
gains come after like six weeks
um and i want to see that's true you
know and to start monitoring these
things more the truth about insulin and
hgh um
let's see how to not become skinny fat
multivitamins cancer risk and more he
also has a really interesting
unconventional
hair loss routine
that again i'll go into next week but
it's like
nothing i've ever heard of before like
all these vitamins um ketoconazole cream
on your hand which is an anti-fungal
cream and i've used the ketoconazole
shampoo before
um
lots of like like rosemary oil uh
primrose oil a number of different
supplements uh like
taurine but there's literally like 10 of
them and i'll go over them next time but
everything that he puts on there is all
backed by science you know he's going
i'm putting this in here because and
then he gives his justification for it
from scientific studies and people who
he's coached who have restored their
hairlines using these protocols i'm very
excited to test it out
and see
what the results are
okay
do we got time for hella chef harley oh
yes okay so this is something it's more
complicated than i normally do right i'm
usually in here just giving you diet
hacks and be like yo try this try this
one simple thing however
this is a more complicated recipe i just
happen to have like looked up uh and
thought it'd be fun to make a funfetti
it's even in the name funfetti mini
cheesecake recipe from flexible dieting
lifestyle yeah
you like that christian
you try this out what's that
oh nice
um
so
i'm bringing this up because it's a
little more complicated but sometimes
the fun of baking is like what you're
really going for right it's like baking
soda do you ever bake am i the only
baker here i've been making pies since i
was a little kid yeah i don't bake but
i'm obsessed with the great british
baked show so i could see baking
i watch a lot of bacon i watch
like it's something to do and honestly
sometimes like when you are hungry it
almost like
making yourself make something you know
and like spend the time and doing it um
is a way to not eat you know like in
that time before you eat it but you
don't want to end up with you know an
actual full fat cheesecake that you're
gonna wolf down because i am that person
that if i make you know a loaf of
something or a cheesecake or a pie i'm
eating the whole thing there's no way in
hell that i'm just like i mean this
whole cherry pie like i'm gonna have one
slice and then put it away it's all
going in my stomach that night
because i have an eating disorder now
the macros for this whole thing let's
see which okay yeah macros are 332
calories 33 grams carbs 8 grams fat 32
grams protein so again we have equal
protein and carbs
relatively low fat but it's a pretty
balanced little thing here and it tastes
really good so
first you got to make the crust 130
grams crushed graham crackers 100 grams
plain non-fat greek yogurt 28 grams
light butter
and 30 grams of whey or casein blend
vanilla protein powder so you're going
to use the protein powder in a number of
different steps in this but you mix all
that up in the mixer graham crackers and
the yogurt the butter and the protein
powder you make a crust and then that's
going to be actually the first thing
that you cook is the crust in the oven
before you put the filling in the actual
cheesecake ingredients are
220 grams fat-free cream cheese two
whole eggs or 100 grams egg whites
227 interesting number plain non-fat
greek yogurt 227 grams 60 grams away uh
whey or casein vanilla protein powder 8
grams of zero calorie sweetener of your
choice and 30 grams sprinkles gotta have
the sprinkles in there cannot leave out
the sprinkles okay they're the key
ingredient
if you don't put the sprinkles in there
you're not making a funfetti cheesecake
i hate to break it to you
now onto the protein frosting which
comes obviously after you cook
the graham cracker crust take it out put
the
cheesecake stuff in take that out and
put the frosting on
45 grams way
or casein vanilla protein powder 22
grams powdered sugar actual powdered
sugar 12 grams
sugar-free or fat-free a sugar-free and
fat-free white chocolate pudding mix
that was a little tough to find though i
will say that you might have to go on
amazon or something look up the you know
i don't think a lot of stores are just
randomly having like sugar-free fat-free
white chocolate pudding mix
so go on amazon and get that four grams
of zero calorie sweetener and 60 grams
plain non-fat greek yogurt preheat your
oven to 400 add your crust into the food
processor and pulse until until it's
combined
and kind of wet to the touch add to the
freezer to cool and condense take your
mini four inch cheesecake pans this is
something i had to buy
um
don't do do it ceramic like little pans
don't do an actual like muffin tin or
something like that
mini cheesecake pans and spray with
cooking spray press your dough into
cheesecake molds
you might need to wet your finger
periodically with water to help the
dough be
less sticky on your hands repeat this
process for all five so it makes five
uh add to oven for 10 minutes you're
cooking those little crusts for 10
minutes take them out add your
cheesecake ingredients
um
add your sprinkles and oh yeah put your
cheesecake ingredients into the food
processor
pulse till combined add your sprinkles
once the crust is done baking spray the
cheesecake pan again with more cooking
spray and add your cheesecake filling
turn the oven down to 350 so you had it
400 go down to 350.
bake for another 20 to 25 minutes until
the middle of the cheesecake isn't
completely solid but 80 percent there
let cool in the fridge to set
then you're gonna add the frosting on
slowly add your dry ingredients into a
bowl
and then add cold water and mix and
repeat until you have a thick frosting
so you can slowly control the
consistency of that frosting until it's
perfect
all right was that the longest hella
chef harley ever yes it was i don't care
i hope you try if one person tries this
and can impress their girlfriend with
their high protein cheesecake cooking
skills then it's all worth it isn't it
let's finish off with a little this is
why we can't have nice gems because oh
this is why we can't have nice gyms
let's look at this
first one oh you know there's so much
going on here the guy's got a
weightlifting belt on the biggest gloves
i've ever seen in a gym and also his
head is so small that i borderline feel
guilty about making fun of him because
he's got this little beetlejuice
shrunken head is he mentally handicapped
i don't know but the way that he's doing
this leg press makes it seem like he
might be either that or he's got a wish
to tear all the ligaments in his knee
while at the gym
he's looking at the cameraman like you
see this you see this you see how i'm
gonna rip my acl pcl and mcl and lcl yes
that's all the lateral ligaments in the
goddamn knee
but he ends up you know your whole time
you're you're cringing and going oh
you're bracing for yourself you're
bracing for his knees the whole time
you're bracing for the moment that they
hyper extend but alas they never do
but don't ever leg press like that it's
totally unnecessary just go down deeper
instead of locking out harder go down
deeper crazy concept and we have one
more okay
this is
this one's been going around the
internet this week
you know this is like a gym fail video
that turns into a black dot com video um
she's first of all
my friend was like how do you supposed
to s squat spot somebody from the front
but the thing is she has the uh
thing in the back
the pad that she's sitting on that's too
big so unless you're like on top of the
pad i guess i can see his logic because
it'd be too awkward but they didn't
anticipate what would happen right she
fails at it
comes forward and all of a sudden she's
giving him a simulated [ __ ] in the
middle of the gym
and he's like oh no please don't stop oh
this is crazy how could i have ever
anticipated this happen i definitely
didn't put on extra weight so you'd fail
and end up blowing me in the middle of
this gym stranger who i'm spotting
so this is why we can't have nice gems
because people didn't think through
that series of events
i can just watch what happens if i fail
where's your head gonna be maybe in my
crotch maybe that was the whole point
but it does look real to me i don't
think they planned that out
it looks like a genuine
start of a porno
spontaneously hater of the week oh
we hated the week real quick
this one guy sanders said on my old page
kept commenting every single week just
give it up my man leave thick boy you
might blow up oops here comes the
comment count and the diatribe because
they used to be like i just tell him how
many comments he had you know which is
fun to do like up 47 comments
like you hate the show it sucks oh my
god you're the worst is that why you're
commenting 800 times on the page
next it goes these views are diminishing
quicker than any other channel just quit
papa and save some dignity you insecure
mufasa
oh
how shall i ever recover
insecure mufasa oh no
i've always thought of myself as more of
a secure mufasa
oh here comes the response he says again
and the third time
your views suck ah here comes the novel
in response or comment count
oh and i didn't respond to any of those
comments and i just love it because it's
like he's just trying to like team me up
like it doesn't really it's like i can
see what you comment each time you're
commenting the same oh here comes the
response like
and then if it doesn't
or what if my views go up go up huh
hater of the week sanderson didn't see
you over on the thick boy channel weird
it's almost as if that's your only
critique and if you have no substantive
critique of my podcast besides the view
count then you're a little lost oh what
am i going to [ __ ] on mark for this week
okay what do we have time how long have
we been going casey 36 minutes 36
minutes exactly all right dude i just
want to show you
let's do a physique check real quick
because god damn dude i [ __ ] buff
like a lot of people don't realize it
and it's super funny because it's like
i'm putting it out there all the time
but a lot of people just think that i'm
not super muscular
how do i look right now i think i'm at
about
12 body fat not mad at it my abs are
somewhat prominent so you could see that
but it's like i'm the most lean person
or just wanted to give you an update
because you know maybe like the lighting
in 24-hour fitness is better than it is
in the studio and that's why i'm doing
this
and then uh let's see that back shot
dude can we just absolutely look at my
sweaty ass crack in here okay so that's
where i'm at right now this is after
back there so i got a little bit of a
pump but i am not mad at it 100 grams of
100 grams milligrams of npp
a day and nothing else no testosterone
no other compounds no orals
that's where i'm at i think i'm making
improvements but again i don't take so
many pictures of myself
that i have like week two week to week
to week but been pretty good about my
diet um
i'm okay with my body fat percentage i
want to get leaner
while keeping this same level of
musculatory and getting a little bit
stronger okay can we finish off with the
hella personality portion of the podcast
i keep saying we're gonna finish we're
gonna finish and then i have 18 more
segments
cool bro
okay let's start off with the famous
ones this time i saw some people
do uh
intp in the comments if you want to take
the test and put your results down there
i will eventually get to all the types
and then expand even more
but for now i just want to go through
all them and be like yo these are the
types and they're so sick
bill gates kristen stewart albert
einstein
stanley crouch i don't know that is
isaac newton renee descalt elliott page
formerly of ellen page fame oops did i
just dead name
blaise pascal lord varus of game of
thrones neo from the matrix okay
just to give you a basic sense of what
intps might be all about these are
really smart people i'm an entp anybody
with that nt core the entb intp intj
entj basically they're nerds that's what
you can say
i'm a little bit more of a silly nerd
maybe than some of these other guys but
at my core
i really like ideas i like uh you know
abstraction and stuff like that
an intp is somebody with the introverted
intuitive thinking and perspective
personality traits these flexible
thinkers enjoy taking an unconventional
approach to many aspects of life they
often seek out unlikely paths making
willingness to experiment
uh with personal creativity
albert einstein said the important thing
is not to stop questioning
curiosity has its own reason for
existence logicians pride themselves on
their unique perspectives and vigorous
intellect they can't help but puzzle
over the mysteries of the universe which
may explain why some of the most
influential philosophers and scientists
of all time have been logicians this
personality type is fairly rare but with
their creativity and inventiveness
logicians aren't afraid to stand out
from the crowd
so when i think of an intp in the intps
i've known they're extremely thoughtful
people that like i have a client who's
an intp i believe
who's a chemist he works for beyond meat
and he's just like a you know
an incredibly intelligent thoughtful guy
they spend most of their time like
working out problems in their head um
compared to somebody like an intj who
maybe has those similar qualities but
they're more focused on like
accomplishing things in the real world
but you know
to the outside so they may look lazy
they may look like they're
procrastinating or spending all day
doing nothing but people like albert
einstein sort of proved that stereotype
wrong a lot of people did think he was
stupid and lazy apparently growing up
but the [ __ ] was figuring out
the mysteries of physics and mathematics
in his mind the whole time so
these people are generally pretty sweet
non-confrontational they just like
you know classic like shy nerd type
who's really thoughtful and interesting
and if you engage them in a discussion
they're gonna have some really
interesting unconventional positions
most likely and
are people who you can disagree with and
they're not gonna get offended they like
exchanging ideas intps are
really nerdy most of the time let's be
real but very smart very good friends
good people all around okay
and then you know what one one more
segment casey let's do it one more
hell of a second i want to keep this up
with the hella second dog [ __ ]
i want to talk about dmt
you know
i'm turning this into the joe rogan
podcast have you tried dmt has anybody
in here tried dmt christian no dmt casey
any dmt i haven't you haven't okay i
haven't but my friend did and it was it
kind of scared me from doing it why did
it scare you
um because he just put on like bill
withers music and just stared at the tv
for about 15 minutes it did not move and
it just like we were [ __ ] with him
putting our hands in his face and he
just was not responding you know what's
interesting is i was gonna talk about
that today because
the experience of it i did it at this
like
little you can there's like a trailer
park in joshua tree but it's like really
cool like pimped out trailers that have
like themes to each one of them i'm
forgetting the name of it but me and a
group of people went out there for
vacation that's like the perfect spot to
do it because it's so
colorful and like just almost set up
i know it's like joshua tree and maybe
not exactly in joshua tree hicksville
there we go hicksville trailer palace
this is exactly what it is and uh
hopefully we can see some of the but
like at night like it's almost like set
up perfectly with the lighting and
everything to be this perfect place to
do a psychedelic
dmt specifically we bought a dmt vape
pen
and me and some of my friends
i did it like a few rounds or whatever
right they last like five to ten minutes
and
it was it left me speechless i'm still
struggling to convey the experience i
just know the next day i was going
around to people you know like joe rogan
does like prostitutizing to people have
you tried dmt
because the experience was so powerful
and astounding and i'm not saying that i
learned anything from her like i had
some deep connection to you know
aliens or the purple lady or any of
these other tropes that people will
convey about dmt to sort of add
something either like extraterrestrial
or supernatural to it it was just a
mind-blowing psychedelic experience
because i've done a lot of psychedelics
and this one was the most powerful and
the stillness thing christian i just
wanted to say when you smoke it right or
you you ingest it in some way
you're sitting there
first of all everything kind of goes to
like
this
somebody described it as like an 8-bit
world you know but like
that seems almost uglier than what it is
because
everything becomes like angular and
fractal right so it's this like super
beautiful experience that becomes this
like really rapid display of psychedelic
images
and you feel so content where you are
exactly in that moment that you feel
like you're disrupting it if you move a
muscle and so i remember like i could
hear people talking like oh look at mark
he's doing like and i'm like
i'm not gonna break this to like come
out of like it feels like you're on a
surfboard and you're like traveling
through space and time and like
experiencing like a rapid uh you know
show of psychedelic images that you're
almost like if i go to this way i'm
gonna go dark if i go this way i'm gonna
you know veer into this other thing it
feels like you're riding something and
it's happening so fast and to like move
a single muscle even your head or your
arm or just like like it feels like
you'd throw it out or something so it
was this really
interesting experience that i've never
had before where you're like
i just i i have to stay still and it
looks like i'm comatose even though i'm
fully cognizant of my surroundings while
having this insane you know
it feels like you're going at warp speed
through some it's like condensing an lsd
trip down into five minutes like you see
all the imagery you've seen it's like
you know
maybe not for everybody but it was less
scary than i thought you know i'm always
somebody who's like yeah that looks
scary oh you're traveling to different
dimensions and complete ego death and
all these things that seem like you're
more out of control i just would say
maybe i didn't reach that liftoff point
but i was still in control and i knew
what was going on and i was like let me
do it again
you me and casey will do dmt i swear to
god i thought about that before the way
here i was like we need to do dmt on the
show so if you
write down in the comments you want to
see us do dmt live on the show you know
it's only gonna take five minutes if it
doesn't work we're gonna cut it out but
goddamn that would be a good idea and
i'm so excited i guess i gotta take the
shirt off right i'm gonna do dmt
shirtless on the show if you put in the
comments if we get a hundred comments
saying yes mark do dmt
shirtless i'm the haters we'll say
episode next week i'm gonna do it
because that's how committed i am to
doing psychedelics in front of my
viewership all right so please
express yourself in the comments and if
you don't
that's your loss
come back next week we'll have a
psychedelic show for you all right